we make way for the Giants quarterback
Eli Manning who joins us on behalf of
Gatorade let me clear something up here
because the last time we were together
and there were a few other people there
you were at the Super Bowl and you won
the MVP and I was trying to give you the
keys to a black on black beautiful
Corvette yes so what happened I'm
reading the card that says an Eli
Manning you've got this beautiful
Chevrolet Corvette I turn around and
you're off the podium what happened I
was ready to start celebrating I wasn't
like you know we've got a Corvette here
yeah well I can't drive it off the field
you know did you have a Toyota
sponsorship then I did and that's why I
[Music]
still have my and I still drive it to
you and where is the Corvette the
Corvette is it's down in Mississippi
it's kind of Mississippi come you know
poor bad Mississippi South I think so
it's down it's down there and you know
Cooper my brother coupe drives it all
the time you know it's kind of all right
that's all I wanted to know no it's so
weird because you know there's a hundred
million people watching and I'm reading
this card
I don't think Eli has left me and all of
a sudden and I know we like goes down
the steps if you just fill it off you
have the blueprint to beat knowing I
think so I mean if yeah you look at it
on paper and and the way they've played
this year they've got a great defensive
front they can get to the quarterback
and if you can if you can somehow
disrupt hombre D you got a chance and
they can do that with their with that
that defensive front you know with their
schemes and you know their offense can
control the ball they run the ball so
you know they have it now it's just a
matter of hike and you and the fourth
quarter can they and they slow down Tom
can they keep him from you know can they
play their best football late in the
game that's usually what it comes down
to with these Patriots it feels like
everybody feels like the Patriots got
their signals that they stole their
signals or they understood what signals
there were did the Patriots have your
signals in any of those Super Bowls or
did
I think they know no I don't I don't
think so
and we never we were never worried about
that that I know of and so it's that
part of the gamesmanship that well you
know I think by that by really by the
time by the time I came around it was
everything was kind of in the earpiece
you know it was you know but that's the
offensively they were still some defense
coordinators or old school they like to
signal it in so I mean I guess if you're
on the sideline and you're you can look
and look at the signal and see the
coverage or see the defense and then get
an idea it's a lot I mean it's a lot
going on to see a signal that you know
usually those offense coordinators you
know it's the next play even while that
plays being run they kind of have an
idea what what they're calling so I
don't think you have time to say hey
here's something and then called the
perfect play to beat it I don't think
it's it works quite that way explain to
us explain to the audience what it's
like when you get something in your
helmet and then you go to the line of
scrimmage and then you get something
else in your helmet but then there's the
15-second cutoff right okay 15 seconds
yeah it's cut off there's no no more
communication so forever I've been it's
really you know you just you just get it
one time they call the play oh it
doesn't change yeah and and I guess now
you know I think you know it's I guess
some coordinators may may you know say
hey it may see a defense and say check
the play they can do that before that
fifteen seconds on the play clock is
comes up then you can do that but for us
it was always yeah you just get one play
and then it's up to you if you want to
change the play it's it's on me to know
you know what what play to change it to
when Odell gets injured what's it like
when you go home you talk to your why I
mean how bummed out because you just
lost one of the best weapons in the yeah
yeah I mean for and and at that point it
was not just so Dell we'd lost you know
we lost Brandon Marshall we lost
sterling Shepherd that game and and into
Wayne hair so we lost her top you know
for receivers or so and and kind of top
it off with Odell so yeah I mean yeah
the wife and you know my wife Abby's
like you know who's going to play you
know
next week we you know we finished that
game we have a two minute drive to try
to go win we got we got three tight ends
on the field and one receiver which is
not not your ideal I mean that's usually
kind of your you know you know when you
have the lead and you're holding on to
it you may put you know three tight ends
out there not to go on a two-minute
drive and you know we had a tight end
playing you know wide receiver so it was
it was not ideal but do you give a
generic answer to your wife like yeah
the media you know we have guys guys
practice we had a great practice my guy
he's ready the superstar in the making
will be fine we're talking to Eli
Manning joining us on behalf of Gatorade
are you involved in the draft strategy
at all have you ever been asked about
anything no never never been involved in
the draft just you know want to know
just because you know wouldn't be fair
for me to say hey you need to draft this
person or you know we now draft this
position I mean yeah that's what you
have that's the GM's job that's what the
scouts or those jobs are that that's
what they do all your around it's look
at players scout players so I you know I
see a few highlights of a guy and I say
you know we need to get him I don't know
who the best college players are and so
they they go through all that and you
know so they're gonna draft the player
that they thinks gonna be a great player
that's gonna help us you know
this year and help the Giants the
mountain down the road so you know it's
my job to play quarterbacks their job to
do don't handle the drafting how would
you feel if they took a quarterback at
number two you know I'm hey that's I'm
fine with that I understand the
situation and I know how old I am I know
you know how many more years of football
do I have left who knows that I don't
know so I understand you got to prepare
for the future and so if they want to
take a quarterback number two then hey
it's it's my job to still my job to play
quarterback and do and go out there and
compete and like I've done every every
other year explained to the audience
what you're doing with Gatorade this
week yeah so obviously Gatorade it's
been around 50 years and ever since ever
since I've been in the NFL you go in the
locker room there's always Gatorade to
drink you have the bars you have your
protein powders and every athletes
different and just like you need
different things to supplement yourself
and to get better your tastes are
different so now you got Gatorade flow
is their newest line and we got a little
pineapple mango it's a little smoother
the flows a little smoother finish but
still your normal Gatorade hydrates you
gives you everything - after a great
workout or after a game and so this is
their newest line we dug up your draft
profile okay perfect now we did take
away the good stuff okay yes okay course
so these are just the negatives that
we've found now drew when he's read it
Marino JJ Watt they've all read the
draft profiles Luke Kuechly so here's
Eli Manning's draft profile there you go
you want to read it yeah will force
balls in the coverage check good use
more bulk on his frame not athletic I
disagree I disagree I can I can dunk
really yeah you know what year is this
this is like no this is college this is
oh yeah then I could dunk then sure at
Ole Miss you can dunk yeah deep throws
could be more accurate okay
streaky passer and needs to protect the
ball better so yeah it sounds wonderful
[Laughter]
did you ever read this draft profiles
when you know coming out no I don't
think they were available back I don't
think you had all the all the you know
access these guys have way too much now
it's all access Brees took his draft
profile home with him oh really he was
so up like he said can I keep this he's
like bothered of Aaron Rodgers took his
home yesterday like he folded up put it
in his pot not that you have to but
those guys were like oh I could use this
yeah I could use this okay so we've had
Alex Smith on the show Aaron Rodgers
some of these guys have thrown the
football to McLovin so just two passes
okay
McLovin is an Eagles fan and I don't
know if that affects how you throw right
but if you
so McLovin if you would like to just
want to say I've always dreamed of
catching a pass from a Manning the
greatest man in Cooper but I'll take you
all right so Eli Manning if you're
watching on DirecTV the audience network
channel 239 in the MVC Sports Network
dressed in his Giants blue sweater by
the way and McLovin OMA Clemons gonna
put on an Eagles hello Eagles shirt and
so yeah we sort of have it
well everybody all the great ones do Eli
are you going Dawkins or something yeah
well you know let's be more realistic
Eagles defense we have a you could be
moderate level and then you can bring
whatever you want to bring towards
McLovin and there's a bull's-eye on his
helmet if you want to aim there all
right there we go
all right that's good
here we go
[Laughter]
I once won more McLovin oh no no duck no
ducking alright here we go
yeah I would have caught that with one
hand Eli thank you for coming in Eli
Manning on behalf of Michaels drum
exists next year on the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]